in his Christmas message President Trump
called for unity and respect from his
private club in Palm Beach 24 hours ago
the president said House Speaker Nancy
Pelosi hates the Republican Party and
all Trump voters while complaining about
the impeachment stalemate one Senate
Republicans taking issue with the white
house working with the Senate Majority
Leader on impeachment strategy
correspondent rich Edson's down in West
Palm Beach following the president with
the dueling narratives of respect and
politics good evening rich hey good
evening Mike and for president Trump a
Christmas break from discussing
impeachment at least publicly the
president spending his holiday privately
with his family of mar-a-lago as
Democrats and Republicans debate their
impeachment strategies if there is a
trial in the Senate a Christmas
greetings from the President and First
Lady we give thanks for the millions of
Americans who come together to care for
others with compassion and bring the
warmth and bliss of this holy season to
our families our friends our neighbors
and to those in need and as liberal and
conservative Americans sit sometimes at
the same table for Christmas dinner the
president's re-election campaign is
offering some tips how to win an
argument with your liberal relatives
snowflake victory calm arms Trump
supporters with suggestions to best
their liberal so-called snowflake
cousins or siblings by boasting about
the economy and trade agreements end
quote there was no quid pro quo
Democrats always obsessed with
impeachment though Democrats contend the
President did withhold aid from Ukraine
to compel its president to investigate
the Biden's and a week ago the House
impeached the President on partisan
lines on that charge and obstruction of
Congress
I hope we're all gonna find a way that
as we go into this impeachment trial
we're going to look at the facts the
Senators will be all impartial make up
their minds and we're gonna all protect
the democracy that we love House Speaker
Nancy Pelosi is withholding the
impeachment articles to try to force
Senate Republicans to allow witnesses in
any impeachment trial Republican senator
Lisa Murkowski of Alaska just told a
local television station that she was
disturbed when she heard Majority Leader
Mitch McConnell was in total
coordination with the White House on a
Senate impeachment trial McConnell has
called impeachment a political charade
there is one more holiday message from
the president this Christmas a tweet
congratulating America on strong holiday
sales Mike Richardson live in West Palm
Beach rich thanks a lot